all right michelle
michelle where did you grow up where are
you from originally um i'm from los
angeles california east delhi
specifically
and tell me about your family growing up
you had both your parents um no i didn't
grow up with both my parents uh i grew
up with my father um who got sole
custody of me
when i was about like two because um my
mom chose um more tumultuous lifestyle
down here on skid row so oh really your
mom came to schedule yeah
you were holding um about like two or
three when he got full custody
um she did like a prison term somewhere
in between that where um
kind of vaguely remember seeing her as a
child but not really
but me and my dad lived with my
grandparents so your mom was into drugs
yeah
how would you describe your childhood um
for the most part
as a youth good like um with my
grandparents and my father before um his
drinking really took a toll like i mean
being younger um kind of left the reins
to like my aunts and uncles who had all
had like children my age so i grew up
with a lot of cousins like family
vacations were a thing um until i got to
like middle school my dad's drinking
really took into play
and just started causing chaos with the
rest of my family and so that pull
between
the rest of my family and my dad
you know thinking like my dad's my
knight is shining armor you know like
save me from my drug addict mom
kind of do like it's kind of hard always
going back and forth with him like
because it was never the right choice uh
he ended up being
verbally abusive emotionally abusive and
then at some point physically abusive
when
he couldn't just toss me to the rest of
my family anymore yeah yeah
so um
yeah
um but for the most part um i was
blessed to have my grandparents and my
aunts and uncles
um but just
i always felt like black sheep alone
because it was just always like a burden
you know like um
kind of like my grandparents would
always like shoot the rest of my family
extra money to take me on those
vacations that i was so blessed to have
you know like we're just like did you
have siblings
i there's a ten years difference
um between me and my youngest brothers
yeah it's almost not really yeah and
then um i'm the only one from me
for my mom and my dad specifically
um i have a younger brother from my mom
who's also down here on skid row
hopefully still alive
at this point i haven't heard from him
in about a week
um he's only 25
um
but and i have two younger brothers from
my dad but um
he ended up staying married to their mom
um they're still married
um but
me and her have a love-hate relationship
um in the best way
worst way
you've been down here on skid row for
how long
um i've been here about a year now
um were you homeless before that
um well i've already like
since
even high school i've had a bounce
around like from
like friends houses where like families
took me in because it's just either i
didn't want to follow the rules at my
grandparents house or you know just one
too many curfews broken
or i started drinking in high school so
you know that really bothered you know
just the strict catholic family that i
came from so to speak so it was just
always like if you don't like it get the
[ __ ] out so like bye
kind of
in a sense but
um
so like not so to speak homeless before
in high school but like bouncing around
from friends to friends houses for
however many months at a time that i was
able to
and even thereafter yeah and eventually
that ran out and you ended up homeless
well um i mean
i i worked for a majority of time two or
three jobs trying it like on my own
um
[Music]
shacked up with a couple boyfriends you
know still paying my dues but um after
my last relationship um he caught a
domestic violence case
on that note so i'm a survivor on that
note but i lost the apartment covet hit
um i also lost my grandfather so
depression hit me super hard
um
and just like the frailty of everything
so
i was in my car probably for six months
before i got here
but um a big part of it is
my drinking and my drug use now
um
just having to deal with
the lack of support
not being able to talk about
past trauma from my early 20s
and then um
also too just
being tired
like not to be like sob storage because
you know i'm still blessed i mean got a
biscuit
um
just even now i can't
go back
officially to my grandparents house
because i'm that wild card that they're
afraid of
because i have explosions i'm like
bipolar but i'm also an alcoholic
and now like addicted to meth
i feel like
so
it's just
i'm not the most stable person to
necessarily have around right where did
you go through in your 20s
at 19 i was raped
by multiple people blacked out at a
party
so um
it's just
something like i blacked out like
for a very long time up until recently
where like it triggered me like we're
just like [ __ ]
like oh that's why like you know like a
lot of things clicked and made some
swear
it's just like
i don't know it's so like kind of like
kind of still don't believe it like it
was kind of like just one of those
[ __ ] up dreams you know like you would
have a thing to suddenly realize
yeah it's just like
like a lot of my volatile behavior comes
from like you know like
i guess
ptsd from that you know without like
knowing it where like
i blocked a lot of it out
just having to function and like
survive so to speak by myself you know
just like i didn't have time to like
wallow and then just
being embarrassed to like
go to my family tell them
like they wouldn't believe me if they
did it'd be my fault like
for putting myself in that situation a
lot like
i feel like the situation i'm in now
like
i mean
i'm a grown adult you know like i should
i should be able
i mean i am able
i will be able
to get it together you know
we're not out of choices yet how biscuit
but um yeah i lost um
the last apartment i was in and the last
relationship i was in
um
about
two years ago
um i was in my car for like five months
um and then
i got a shelter at the weingart
um i lost that recently so so you had a
roof over your head for a while
um at the wine yard
um well not well not that recently um
i mean i guess time flies when you know
living life in the fast lane
um where are you now in a tent
yeah
that's gonna be rough
it is because they were about biscuit
and then it's just like everybody like
us just being females and being female
down here is tough yeah
but it's just hard like just being down
here by yourself like
well just being on skid row is
depressing alone
yeah
and then just not feeling safe and then
just
not even being sure if you could trust
someone you're with you know
but she's like constantly questioning
like
where do we go from here and she's like
trying to step away like
[ __ ] do you feel like you're
like walking in the footsteps of your
mouth
yeah
where it's like
[Music]
it's kind of like what kind of hits me
the hardest because like
my dad would get abusive with me like as
a teenager he'd be drunk and like out of
his mind and
getting physical and like calling me a
[ __ ] at like 12 or you know like what
would he talk like and i'd cry
you'd be like and he called me he'd call
me her name
like thinking i was her
you know and i mean
we are very similar in like
liking so it's just like i mean i feel
like a lot of his abuse was like the
grievance towards her like having to
pick up whatever pieces she wasn't there
for like whatever she did to him but
like
i was just a little kid you know like
i went to like a private grade school
like
sex and all that like wasn't even on my
mind like at that time
where it's like um i was told that um i
made up that um i was molested by um
a neighbor when i was um
like in fourth grade so
it was just always like that shame and
guilt like of not being sexual to begin
with
so it's just
i don't know it's a really sensitive
issue for me because it's just not my
personal personal you know like in any
kind of way where it's just
to be called that as a child i just
translated and then
with the rape later that's why i
couldn't go back and
like say anything about it but
that took like a huge toll
just like on my bean like
where it's like the drinking spiraled
and then a drink is filed so then you do
drugs to keep up with the drinking and
then the drugs are in and out so the
drugs get harder
your life unravels
yeah
it surely
i guess slowly yes but
not completely
i mean you still have help yeah
definitely i mean
still young so blessed i got you're home
i'm 35 35 yeah i mean got two hands i
mean unmanicured hands
um
she's on my feet
i got a biscuit she's fed
but
she's honestly saved my life also
because like my depression hits so hard
where it's just like
when i do drugs i feel like i at least
them in tow of my emotions like other
than that they're like everywhere some
of that helps with your depression
somewhat because i know like what i feel
when i'm on crystal meth like
other than that like it's just
i feel like my bipolar is just like my
depression hits and it's like my lows
like if they're demobilizing like so
like because like at least i can get out
of bed because i'm like uh i'm out yeah
right
i don't know it's like
i've tried like pharmaceuticals they
don't work i mean not as quickly as
crystal meth
but
um
hopefully soon
i mean i don't plan on being on drugs
forever
is this your lowest point right now
yeah
yep
okay i got no phone
got no home
barely holding on to family by a thread
you're friends at all
kind of cut off myself from all my
friends because i'm embarrassed
like i've suffered fruit like i've been
abused while down here like i didn't
have these scars on my face before i got
here like
every time i show up there's like
like another injury like
so i don't talk to anyone from like
my other life my past life like
and like my friends friends down here is
just like i don't know if they like
just want to drug me up screw me and
like you know tells me to slide or you
know turn me into a hell like kill me
like i
no one should like really trust
you don't have children
no
luckily
i mean not luckily children are blessing
but
i mean everything happens for a reason
and i miscarried twice so
um
yeah how do you support yourself now
government assistance and then to like i
also
try and sell whatever personal
belongings like i had just like on a
like
past life like tools or clothes or
just electronics that aren't needed
anymore because
i don't have electricity
you know
um
stuff like that
ngr
you haven't had to resort to
the darker ways of supporting yourself
um
not not specifically but i feel there's
this like
culture happening like around me that
just like kind of like
whether you're actually
doing it or not like you're portrayed in
that like sense where like you know like
i don't know like what benefit it does
to them like or
for them but it's just
i don't
and it's so hard because then it's just
like is it the drugs is it like actually
like a subculture of like instance like
am i using my [ __ ] mind like
but
luckily no i haven't had to fully resort
to
that but i mean you know
people um who say to trust them you know
i can't always trust so
it could just be hidden
alter your
motives behind whatever comfort they're
trying to
assimilate for whatever reason
what are you afraid of what are you most
afraid of
well my mom while she was here
got hit by a car
shattered her pelvis
where like i hadn't seen her in eight
years when that had happened
um where i got a call from a random
security guard and i had to call every
hospital in the city try and find her
i did her pelvis was shattered like um
totally like
an instance but i ended up having to
leave her at the hospital because there
was no way for me to bring her back into
her she came back to skid row she ended
up getting shot in the face
so really ending up like my mom is like
really ultimately
what i'm terrified of
because she was shot in the face because
um you know she liked to get high she
would do
whatever she did i mean i don't know if
for certain i haven't heard it out of
her but you know i hear stories i hear
she was a
vivacious character of sorts
but because they were trying to rape her
and she didn't want to have sex for
whatever drugs you know she was
screaming and being loud about it
because she's loud they shot her in the
mouth
threw them out like they shot her in the
mouth like through the map then like
tossed her out the tank put a gun in her
mouth pulled the trigger and tossed her
out the tent
because she was screaming
you should die
no thank god
yeah
yeah
i mean but i don't want to have to get
shot in the face to get the [ __ ] out of
here
yeah so that's like the ultimate fear
like i mean but you know like by god's
grace and she's still here but like you
know what if i'm not that lucky
or like
also too like what happened to biscuit
huh
what happened to my mom
we're like um
yeah
i try and just keep my um
head down mind my peace and keys be
respectful like you know keep my same
like
manners always
manners and values i was raised with
and hopefully not like let this be like
my ultimate pitfall
but this is the lowest of lows but if
this is the lowest lows then
you know hopefully you know like they
say there's only one way up
hopefully
would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
not to value material things so much
it's value people
and their spirit and their energy
because a lot of people down here
do have good sense of humor do have good
hearts
it's just you know
[ __ ] just hits fans sometimes
value people more than material
possessions
all right michelle
thank you so much for sharing your story
yeah thank you
i wish you a biscuit a lot of luck yeah
she's my um she's my essa she's my
emotional supporter
her home girl she's cute
she's the smartest girl big
you